this is Wendy my spell little dragon boy
I've always thought it looked like Spyro
but now I think you look like dude 'less
hi pretty girl
hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara just saw and last
night I went and saw how to train your
dragon three hidden worlds the Sun is a
little bright I think I might be a
little overexposed so excuse that it's
very early in the morning
I loved this movie I hadn't seen up
until yesterday any of the other how to
train your dragon movies though I've
heard the most amazing things about them
I watched one while I was doing dishes
and cleaning up around the house so I
didn't get the full greatness of it I
definitely am gonna watch one in two
hopefully later today because three was
amazing but anyways I got the gist of
the characters and kind of got the gist
of the background of what I was getting
into with three it's a fake glasses
something happened to hiccups dad into I
see that now that I saw three I think
that's the only thing that I missed
though not watching fully one or two I
would give this movie an A+ for
animation an A+ for character work and
relationships formed I would give it
probably a C for action and a C for
comedy and those things just grew less
and less important to me as I watched
the movie I can't decide what look I
want the story is mostly about about
finding the love of his life a light
fury a bright fury it's a joke in the
movie a light fury I think and
ultimately mating with this other dragon
and that's where the best moments of the
film come in is where the best comedy
comes in where the best character work
comes in and it's just the best part of
the movie there's also I guess people
would argue the bigger plot of grimille
the bad guy who is pretty boring but
ultimately pretty unimportant he's a
dragon hunter and he is trying to get
toothless from hiccup hiccup and Astrid
and the other couple Viking warriors I
don't like the group of people that
hiccup has in his life I think they're
so annoying I don't think they're funny
especially the twins are just
insufferable I really don't like them
they probably grow with you for their 1
in 2 more so than jumping right in 3
maybe it was just like a little abrasive
but I did not enjoy them at all
I think the side characters are very
hit-or-miss hiccup and Astrid though I
love their relationship growing in this
hiccup and toothless just the MVPs
character wise they're growing together
is so good and it's all about letting go
and by the end I was just in tears in
this theater from this animated film
that I hadn't really seen one or two of
the animation is just bonkers it's so
beautiful there's this one point where
they're coming up on the hidden world
and it's this giant waterfall and it
looks like a real waterfall or it looks
like it looks better than any CGI and
like the new Jurassic Park Jurassic
world movie if there's a waterfall that
it looks like better than like something
that's trying to be real life that CGI
this is like animated it just looks so
good going into the hidden world I wrote
down in my notes that I thought it
looked like a better cocoa
I love Pixar I loved cocoa and this I
hate to say it was like a better in my
mind a better version of the dead area
in cocoa which it is the term that it
was beautiful and colorful and details
and just crazy crazy crazy crazy good I
imagine one and two are the same way I
love toothless with all of my heart he
reminds me of my cat Wendy who reminds
me of Spyro the Dragon toothless is like
this
kitten cats whale salamander really cute
really goofy very determined fierce
clumsy hilarious
no dialogue but they just know the
character so well the these people
creating this film and this story and
the animation that it just it comes
through as you know who toothless is you
know what toothless is all about you
know toothless I wrote toothless and
hiccup are the friends we need in this
tumultuous world I don't even know if
that's how you use tumultuous but term
uh Lewis term Ultima swirl does it
terminal Chi was mean like crazy no idea
some of the comedy worked for me most of
it didn't and I think that might be just
because I haven't seen one in two I
haven't really grown with these
characters like most other people seeing
this I like that they made fun of
Vikings thinking the earth was flat it's
really cute everything with toothless
and hiccup were really cute and funny
the little band of friends didn't do it
for me I I can't imagine it doing it for
really anyone I just didn't find them
funny at all especially the twins they
were so unfunny to me that that was
really the biggest thing that took away
from the film for me the biggest
negative point the film was the twins
who I just don't think we're funny and
maybe they've grown and like it's a
thing that you you had to be there kind
of deal but they were not for me the
action was good I think I really enjoyed
the lack of action in this because the
story while it was about hiccup moving
everyone from their land of Berk or bird
or whatever to a new place because this
dragon hunter was after them it really
was about the characters and the story
within what they're going through
internally and I just don't care about
grimille and the dragon hunters and the
action
the end was resolved very quickly there
was no giant crazy build-up and then
this 20-minute action-adventure scene
that I don't care to see in this you
know animated film I just don't care to
see it so it's really cool that it was
appropriately built up appropriately
resolved we're done bing-bang-boom
let's see some more dragons and cry and
you know what that should be assured I
think with my cat Wendy on the end
climax of the adventure was really sweet
it was kind of a self sacrifice to save
someone you love and then it ends up
you're saved because of that love and it
was just it was really sweet and I was
left kind of like okay that was a very
cute kind of not the emotional impact I
thought it was gonna happen but really
really great and then right after the
action climax there was just the best
emotional climax ever where I'm just
sitting in this theater surrounded by
children just like sniveling to myself
because it was so good I imagine this is
the last room they're gonna make and it
seems to be a really really nice wrap up
to this series it made me want to go
back and really sit down and watch one
and watch two I'm a pretty easy get when
you're trying to get someone to cry in a
movie and this one definitely got me I
love the voice acting and the animation
is stellar I love the character work I
think that it was really smart of them
to focus mainly on that versus just a
story that really isn't that important I
think from what I read on like online
synopsis of one into those were maybe
better like stories as like a giant
chunk and this was more about wrapping
up these characters that people have
grown to love also any movie that
reminds me of my cat Wendy the 6-pound
was tiny dragon or Ike my 14 pounds
orange chalk
hi there of them is gonna be a win in my
book thank you so much for watching I
will see you all next week with what
what am I
next week climax Greta Tyler Perry's
Ahmadiyya family funeral or the boy who
harnessed the wind for movies I have not
heard of but let me know down below what
you would prefer me to see out of those
are those the only movies coming out let
me know what you want to see for next
week I will read them thank you so much
for watching oh look it's my cat Wendy
oh there she goes again sparks
[Music]